[Musik]
die Malediven für viele Inbegriff eines
Traums
weiße Sandstrände Luxus Resorts und eine
paradiesische Unterwasserwelt
doch auch hier gibt es sie die Toten
Riffe
durch steigende Wassertemperaturen
Bauprojekte und Fischerei sind heute
bereits 50% aller Korallenriffe weltweit
zu steinbösten verkommen
Menschen zerstören aber es gibt auch
solche die wieder aufbauen
der Basler Aki allergoli und sein Team
retten Korallen und pfostenriffe auf
eisernen
konnte
so stark okay ich nehme das Risiko auf
der ehemalige Bänker hat sein Luxusleben
in der Schweiz aufgegeben um auf der
ganzen Welt Korallen zu pflanzen
[Musik]
aus dem einstigen Lebemann und Bänker
Aki allergoli wurde der korallengärtner
[Musik]
hier in Soneva Fushi wo andere
luxusferien machen arbeitet das
korallent-team seit einem Monat auf
Hochtouren
sechs Tage in der Woche Schwerstarbeit
wir entscheiden wie wir uns am
Nachmittag fühlen also nur ein Tauchgang
heute morgen ja okay
die vielen Tauchgänge dieses Monats
gehen langsam an die Substanz des Teams
und trotzdem bleibt die Faszination fürs
Tauchen
Familie
[Gelächter]
hat im Jahr 2016 die NGO Coral live
gegründet über zehn Projekte in aller
Welt hat er schon initiiert dieses Jahr
auf den Malediven ist mit Abstand das
größte bisher
15.000 Korallen sollen hier gepflanzt
werden
jetzt haben wir der erste morgenaufgang
und
drüben
sein Team besteht aus jungen Biologen
und Biologinnen aus der ganzen Welt
Australien Belgien Schottland und der
Schweiz
jeden Tag bringen lokale Fischer ca 500
Korallen in einem speziellen Fischerboot
haben Sie diese über 100 km hierhin
transportiert damit die heikle Fracht
überlebt muss das Wasser innerhalb des
Bootes ständig zirkulieren
normalerweise werden diese Boote für den
Transport lebendiger Fische genutzt
die Korallen wurden von einer
Großbaustelle gerettet in der Nähe der
hauptstadtmale baut der Staat einen
neuen Handelshafen um Land zu gewinnen
wird dort ein Riff zugeschüttet zwei
bewirtschaftliche Erfolg und der
wirtschaftliche Wachstum ist natürlich
wichtiger als
Schutz vor
so wichtige
[Musik]
die Korallen müssen sich nun vom
Transport erholen und an die neuen
Bedingungen gewöhnen Salzgehalt pH-Wert
Nährstoffe und Licht
auf den Tischen werden sie
zwischengelagert und können dann nach
ein paar Monaten ins Riff gepflanzt
werden
[Musik]
aus rund 430 solcher Tische besteht der
Korallengarten er hat Platz für 50.000
Korallen
es ist nicht nur Akis größtes Projekt
sondern auch ein außergewöhnliches ganze
korallenkolonien zu verpflanzen ist
selten möglich normalerweise müssen aus
kleinen korallenstücken zuerst große
Korallen gezüchtet werden
das Spezielle an dieser Technik die
korallentische werden mit ganz wenig
Strom versorgt das erhöht den pH-Wert
und macht das Meereswasser rund um die
Tische kalkhaltiger
Kalk ist das Baumaterial der Korallen
der Strom schafft also eine Umgebung die
sich positiv auf das Wachstum auswirkt
so wachsen sie doppelt so schnell
[Musik]
ist Grundlage mein Grundlagen stimmt
von der marine Ökosystem denn
alle anderen
Deal mit einem Luxushotel eingegangen
der staatliche Bau des neuen Hafens in
male soll wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung
und noch mehr Tourismus ermöglichen
dafür wird aber ein Riff zerstört
alles
Tourismusbranche Interesse zeigt hat
besser und dementsprechend Projekt
nach einer Stunde sind die Korallen
ausgeladen jetzt taucht auch noch der
Chef ab und hilft dem Team dabei die
Fragmente anzubinden
[Musik]
aus diesen Fragmenten sollen in ca einem
Jahr große Korallen Kolonien entstehen
[Musik]
nach über einer Stunde unter Wasser
haben wieder ein paar Korallen ein neues
zu Hause gefunden
[Musik]
mit der Aufforstung beauftragt das
Projekt verfügt über ein Budget von
300.000 Franken finanziert vom Hotel und
Spenden ein neues Hausriff lässt man
sich hier einiges kosten
das korallenthem ist vorübergehend in
einem freien Bungalow einquartiert ganz
schön luxuriös wie selten bei seinen
Projekten wer als Hotel Gast hier
übernachten will bezahlt im Minimum 1500
Franken pro Nacht mit bartknos und
morgen Dirks bespricht Aki den kommenden
Abend
wir müssen es warten groß zu denken
nicht mit ein paar Stückchen
korallenrumalbern ich bin sowieso zu
groß für Smalltalk
mit mir
Aki bekommt die Möglichkeit an einem
exklusiven Apero für geladene Hotelgäste
sein Projekt zu vermarkten
Geldbeschaffung da wo mehr als
ausreichend vorhanden ist für eine NGO
eine attraktive Option
[Musik]
sogar Tote Korallen faszinieren und
werfen bei Angestellten vor Ort Fragen
auf wie lange behalten Sie die Farbe
also die Farbe ist nicht echt die haben
wir aufgesprüht es soll ein bisschen
künstlich aussehen wenn sie sterben
bleibt nur noch das Gerüst übrig
das lebende Gewebe das der Koralle die
Farbe gibt ist eine Alge und die alte
lebt in Symbiose mit dem Polypen der ein
Tier ist
gute schnelle Erklärung
auf einer Sandbank wird für die
exquisite Kundschaft einmal pro Woche
ein sonnenuntergangsabero organisiert
akkis ziel ist es Patenschaften für
korallentische zu verkaufen noch vor
wenigen Jahren betreute er Bankkunden
aus diesen Kreisen
du eventuell
Jojo ich bin hier beim Wasser mit der
Korallen aber das ist halt genauso
wichtig
und die Sache jetzt machen damit der was
man macht
tut mir gut ist und Rede davon
immer mit der Bank
und ja
unter Wasser wird dann ein Schälchen mit
dem Namen vom Partner an den Tisch
gehängt Preis 1000 Franken pro Tisch
läuft
[Musik]
mindestens drei und fünf wäre toll ich
glaube an dich
nur kein Druck oder genau
diskretion wird in diesen Kreisen groß
geschrieben die Kamera hat auf Distanz
zu bleiben die Kaufbereitschaft ist aber
eher bescheiden
ja
[Musik]
nimmt keine Lösung
ein paar Tage später kauft ein Gast doch
noch zwei Tische alles läuft diskret ab
[Musik]
i kennt sich aus auch wenn er vor 14
Jahren dieser Gesellschaft den Rücken
gekehrt hat
im Spiegel arg liebt und und also die
Augen und Gesicht ist
schwach gefühlt
ersten
Glück zum Glück
meistens meistens gut in der Mensch an
und seit Jahren im schalt mehr Vitamin
oder nimmst du halt dir dir die
Medikamenten
und seine Zuschauer ziehen
und ziehen die Video bringt einfach auf
der Strecke
Basel einmal pro Jahr kommt AG für ein
zwei Monate in die Schweiz
[Musik]
in Basel als Sohn eines Iraners und
einer Schweizerin aufgewachsen hat
Wirtschaft und Informatik studiert und
eine steile Karriere bei der Bank Sarah
sehen hingelegt gleichzeitig hat er in
der Basler Partyszene mit gemischt
und es ist ja eine Erinnerung dass Sie
dass ich das eigentlich Hauptsache in
der Nacht gehabt habe
Leistung ansehen Geld und Ehrgeiz
prägten sein Leben was sagst du
fette Haare und wenn dann den Park
fahren und und
in der Bar meistens vom Sonntag morgen
Vergangenheit
alles abgeschlossen
vor 14 Jahren wurde das alles zu viel
und endete in einem Burnout um sich
selbst einen Sinn und einen neuen Weg im
Leben zu finden ging Aki 3 Jahre auf
Reisen in Madagaskar kam er aus
voluntier zum ersten Mal in Kontakt mit
Korallen Aufforstung
wenn er in der Schweiz ist wohnt er bei
Freunden oder der Mutter aber einen
festen Wohnsitz hat er keinen mehr der
46-Jährige ist Single und kinderlos im
Moment zählen nur die Korallen seit
sechs Jahren ist er in der ganzen Welt
unterwegs für seine Projekte
so geil wenn mit dem Flug
übers Internet kauft dann kostet 27 Euro
und wenn es über das 600 83 Euro
FL wo mehr in der Organisation mache die
die sind kompensiert mit
Credits also CO2 Zertifikat gesamte
Kilometer sind das CO2 wo produziert
wird nur zum fütterwerk wo man machen da
da wird neutralisiert
ob es aus der richtigen
[Gelächter]
CO2 für die CO2 Ausstöße in velly
Projekte dass ihr ihnen fließen und mit
Damenwahl den Mangrove planst wo
wirklich unglaublich stark sind im CO2
ebay also
damalshing aber ich kenne ich kenne die
Projekt wo wo wo denn das Sabine jo jo
nein
die Zeit in der Schweiz nutzt er auch um
neue Projekte aufzugleichen Kontakte zu
knüpfen oder zu pflegen
Marc Kaiser ein alter Freund hat ihm
eine vortragsmöglichkeit beim Rotary
Club verschafft nicht alle Projekte
haben einen so potenten Geldgeber wie
das auf den Malediven
sucht Geld für ein Projekt in Madagaskar
vor der Präsentation bleibt noch etwas
Zeit um auf die gemeinsame Reise in
Argentinien zurückzublicken
jetzt stell mir ihn in die Dienst und
dann ist eigentlich loswerden angefangen
wirklich mit komplett auf die NGO
konzentriert dann habe ich nur das Tag
und Nacht gehabt ja ich habe jetzt auf
der Strecke bleiben Mensch ich selber
und jetzt muss ich auch wieder fahren
weil
an der schönsten
Monat
später zusammen
[Musik]
geldbeschaffen für die Korallen
Aufforstung ist das eine den
Lebensunterhalt zu bestreiten das andere
bis jetzt zahlt sich AG keinen Lohn aus
sondern investiert weiter in Korallen
Projekte
[Musik]
in den Sommermonaten arbeitet er auf dem
Bau um seine privaten Ausgaben zu decken
zusammen mit Arbeitskollege Martin
Fritschi baut er heute ein Fundament für
einen Schießstand
machen und damit
das Projekt oder so
gute Frage
auf der Arbeit Verbraucher um Geld damit
schaffen oder willst du
dir sieht nutze und und
klar und wenn man denkt dran umsetzen
das Buch da ist geil aber das ganze
Motivation dass ich den kalt
organisiere damit meine projekammer
machen oder in der Umwelt gut und auch
hier gibt's vor allem ein Thema Korallen
und einfach grüßen
die österreichische Schicht vom ISE muss
ich nicht
opfern und oxidiert nicht und dann
rostetten kein Problem
[Musik]
zurück auf den Malediven seit eineinhalb
Monaten werden täglich rund 500 Korallen
geliefert das Team arbeitet auf
Hochtouren und die korallentische werden
immer voller
[Musik]
Leben zieht ins Riff ein die frischen
Korallen ziehen allerlei Tiere an ich
Schildkröten und Octopusse sie machen
das Riff zu ihrem zu Hause
[Musik]
auch die Papageienfische werden von den
neuen Korallen angelockt nicht ganz
unproblematisch für das Korallen Team
[Musik]
in der Koralle bleibt und
dementsprechend können sie dir auch
wissen und das von
unten auch und die Koralle Kolonie vom
Tisch aber Keyer sterngrund haben
relativ schnell reagiere und jedes Mal
wenn halt erledigt ruhig vor Koralle
haben wir denn hier auch auf unsere
Strukturen
die Papageienfische nehmen beim Fressen
kalksteinpartikel auf weil sie den Kalk
nicht verdauen können scheiden sie ihn
wieder aus
[Musik]
daraus entstehen die legendären weißen
Sandstrände der Malediven
inzwischen sind fast alle Korallen
transportiert und auf den Tischen
zwischengelagert in einem nächsten
Schritt sollen die Korallen ins Riff
gepflanzt werden Alex Dad der
Projektmanager macht Tests unter anderem
mit Zement
[Musik]
die Korallen müssen am refixiert werden
um Sturm Wellen und hungrigen Tieren zu
trotzen
für den Feldversuch verwendet das Team
abgebrochene Korallenstücke das Ziel ist
herauszufinden welche die schnellste
günstigste und verträglichste Art von
Befestigung ist zur Auswahl stehen
Zement Epoxy oder man versucht die
Korallen einfach in Löcher zu klemmen
in ein paar Wochen wird sich zeigen
welche Korallen noch leben und am besten
angewachsen sind aber auch die beste
Technik ist keine Garantie dass die
Korallen überleben werden
steigende Wassertemperaturen und andere
Umwelteinflüsse belasten die
empfindlichen Geschöpfe schwer das
ursprüngliche Riff ist 2016 in Folge
einer Korallenbleiche abgestorben
[Musik]
sind vor relativ flacher Wasser zwischen
1 bis 2 Meter durchaus Wasser meistens
sehr sehr warm die haben sich also über
die letzten Jahre sieht der letzte
Bleaching Event sehr sehr stark an die
neue Umstand gewöhnt also die sehen sehr
sehr resistant
zwei Monate
vorher sagt das ist eventuell wieder ein
Bleaching Event für die Haare
[Musik]
ist es wirklich so einfach ein Riff
umzusehen
[Musik]
am nächsten Morgen hat Aki Neuigkeiten
ein kurzfristiges Ereignis ändert die
Pläne ein bisschen für die nächsten zwei
Tage ich wurde gebeten beim Ted Talk
über unser Projekt zu sprechen
durch einen Zufall erhält Aki die
Möglichkeit an einem internationalen
innovationsevent seine korallenmission
in die ganze Welt zu verbreiten diese
Chance will er packen
[Musik]
es hat sich verändert am Anfang waren
wir viel zusammen und Strand und im
Wasser haben alles zusammen gemacht
rumgelaufen und ausprobiert aber je
größer diese Projekte werden desto
weniger sehen wir ihn er organisiert die
Logistik
muss nun im Eiltempo eine 15-minütige
Präsentation vorbereiten darum geht das
Team heute alleine tauchen
Bart Knaus ein erfahrener Talker berät
ihn noch kurz bevor es losgeht
was denken Sie wie viel Bänke ist noch
in Aki
nicht so viel er ist zu weich er ist
kein Banker mehr
keinen Karrierewechsel im Alter von 32
Jahren gemacht mit seinem letzten Geld
hat er Korallen gekauft richtig
das war ein Griechenland ich darf das
nicht laut sagen weil wir haben das
unter dem Radar gemacht das ist der
Banker der Bänker ist noch HIER Ihr habt
das unter dem Radar gemacht ja
Talk die Plattform für innovative Ideen
da wo sonst zum Beispiel Elon Musk oder
Greta Twin Berg ihre Botschaften in die
Welt verbreiten
vor vielen Leuten aufzutreten ist sich
AG gewöhnt in seiner Jugend war er ein
Basketball Talent hat es bis in die
Schweizer Nationalmannschaft und dann
mit 19 in ein college-team in den USA
geschafft
Basketballspiel
angespannt und dann
gut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die
präsentationsgelegenheiten sind heiß
begehrt live aufgezeichnet werden die
talks schließlich über die
Online-Plattform in die ganze Welt
verbreitet
[Applaus]
jetzt muss ich nicht funktionieren
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
am nächsten Morgen
das Projekt geht langsam dem Ende zu
sowieso
[Musik]
transportiert
den Heizkissen
raus und so ein bisschen unglaublich
einzigartig das muss man mit der
Champagner
Vieren und Feste
spawning heißt die Korallen Leichen ein
sehr seltenes Ereignis es tritt jedes
Jahr nur in einzelnen Nächten auf aber
jetzt müssen zuerst die letzten Korallen
ausgeladen werden
[Musik]
mit dem Platzieren der allerletzten
Koralle ist für Aki und sein Team ein
Meilenstein erreicht
[Musik]
wenn sich die Korallen heute Abend
tatsächlich auch noch fortpflanzen
würden wäre das für Aki und das Projekt
wie ein Sechser im Lotto
[Musik]
dann abends um 11 Uhr taucht das Team
voller Hoffnung in den Korallengarten ab
und tatsächlich die Korallen Leichen
mehrere tausend orange Eier stehen zum
Abwurf bereit
[Musik]
nachdem die ei- und spermienbündel
freigesetzt wurden steigen sie langsam
an die Oberfläche der
befruchtungsprozess beginnt
ist das der Anfang eines neuen
Korallenriffs
[Musik]
drei Monate später
aki ist kurz in der Schweiz mit
schlechten Neuigkeiten Sturm hoher
Wassertemperaturen schlechte
Wasserqualität und ein
Krankheitsausbruch haben den Korallen
zugesetzt eine harte Landung in der
Realität
ist einfach
die ganze Koralle zerstört
[Musik]
scary
praktisch
das ja also
30 40 % gesehen
[Musik]
es scheint also nicht so einfach zu sein
ein Korallenriff umzusiedeln aber AG
gibt nicht auf
immerhin die Hälfte der Korallen hat es
geschafft das macht Hoffnung Aki macht
weiter denn jede Koralle zählt
[Musik]